الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
دعت كيف نتيا 10 دوله بين المانيا وتركيا
الى تزويدها بدبابات ليوبارت بينما حذرت
موسكو الغرب من استمرار تزويد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه وقالت ان اي استهدافا للقرن
سيكون شديد الخطوره لف تسليح اوكرانيا كان
حاضرا ايضا في مباحثته لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي
والامن والالمانيه في برلين قبل اجتماع
لحلفاه اوكرانيا في المانيا يوم غد وايا
للمتابعه ينضم الينا من موسكو مراسل
الجزيره امين درغامي ومن كيف مراسله
الجزيره كاترين حنا ابدا معك كاترين وعود
كثيره الان باسلحه متطوره الى اوكرانيا
الى اي مدى يشعر الاكرامون بالثقه ازاء
تنفيذ هذه الوعود
[تصفيق]
نعم زين فعلا يتزايد الزخم هنا في
اوكرانيا في ما يتعلق بسعيها للحصول على
مزيد من المساعدات العسكريه لا سيما تلك
النوعيه والثقيله اليوم وصل منذ قليل رئيس
المجلس الاوروبي شارل ميشال الى كيف التقى
قبل قليل ايضا الرئيس الاوكرانيه
فولودينيرنسكي
تحدث خلال هذا لقاء عن انه يتوقع نتائج
ايجابيه من الاجتماع
اوكرانيا هذه الدبابات ننتظر ان تعطي
الاذن في اشاره الى المانيا علما زين ان
الرئيس الاوكراني كان قد المح كذلك الى
همم تاخير المانيا في اعطاء هذا الاذن
خلال مداخله كان قد تحدث فيها في مؤتمر دا
قال ان همم ما تقوله دوله عن انها لن تمد
اوكرانيا بالدبابات الا بعد ان تمدنا بها
دوله اخرى هذا يعتبر استراتيجيه غير صحيحه
بحسب مقاله الرئيس جلنسكي في اشاره الى
المانيا التي نقل عن مستشارها الالماني
بانه همم جاهز للامداد اوكرانيا بالدبابات
في حال قامت الولايات المتحده بذلك ايضا
كان لافتا اليوم في هذا الاطار نفسه بيان
مشترك صدر عن وزيري الدفاع والخارجيه
الاوكرانيين تم التاكيد في هذا البيان
المشترك على حاجه اوكرانيا لمزيد من
المعدات ولتعزيز قدراتها الدفاعيه همم طلب
هذا البيان الدول التي تملك دبابات لاسيه
ما دبابات اثنين امداد اوكرانيا بها تم
تاكيد على انه هناك ضمانات بان هذا هذه
الاسلحه ستستخدم بشكل مسؤول وبشكل حصريا
لتحرير الاراضي المح لا بحسب ما جاء في
البيان المشترك لوزير الدفاع ووزير
الخارجيه ايضا في الاطار نفسه اليوم كان
هناك كلام عن مساعدات السويديه ومساعدات
ايضا من السونيا كل ذلك ياتي في الاطار
الذي تسعى اليه همم اوكرانيا اولا من خلال
رئيسها وكافه المسؤولين فيها الى تسخيم
هذا الدعم لها لانها ترى وتؤكد ان هناك
اشهر ان قادمه سوف تكون حاسمه وهناك
مؤشرات تشير اليها السلطات الاوكرانيه زين
الى ان الاشهر المقبله سوف تشهد معارك
اضافيه وان روسيا تستعد لحرب واسعه النطاق
وطويله الامد وانه لا يمكن الفوز بهذه
الحرب بدون هذه الاسلحه الدفاعيه نستمع
الان الى ابرز ما قاله الرئيس الاوكراني
خلال مداخله له في ذا فويس حول هذا
الموضوع وحول التاخير من قبل المانيا في
اعطاء الاذن من اجل اعاده تصدير الدبابات
الى اوك
لا تتردد وليست هناك حاجه للمقارنه اذا
قلت انك ستعطي الدبابات شرط ان يقدم شخص
اخر الدبابات ايضا او ان تقول انك قوي في
اوروبا لكنني ساساعد اذا ساعد شخص اخر من
خارج اوروبا ايضا يبدو لي ان هذه ليست
استراتيجيه صحيحه
[موسيقى]
من الرئيس الاوكراني للموقف الالماني من
اين مراسل الجزيره عيسى الطيبي ايضا احب
امين درغامي من موسكو لكن قبل ان اعود
اليك عيسى حول هذا الموضوع نريد ان نعرف
المواقف الروسيه من امين درغامي هناك
اسلحه وهنالك وعود باسلحه كثيره ستصل الى
اوكرانيا روسيا تعتبرها همم طبعا لامد
الحرب لكن ركز تحديدا على القرم وقالت ان
همم استهداف القرن من جديد يكون شديد
الخطوره
[تصفيق]
نعم صحيح زين
الرسائل الروسيه ربما كانت واضحه لكن هناك
يلحظ وجود نوع من القلق الممزوج ضربهما
بالتحذير هنا لدى جانب الروسي من تزايد
الحديث اولا عن امكانيه امداد اوكرانيا
باسلحه بعيده المدى يمكن همم من خلالها
استهداف اراضي شبه جزيره القرم السفير
روسيا لدى واشنطن همم
قال بانه من السداجه الاعتقاد بان روسيا
لن ترد على تلك الاسلحه التي تريد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم ارسالها
الى اوكرانيا من اجل استهداف او غير
متواعد بالرد وقال بان كل تلك الاسلحه
سيتم تدميرها وسيتم ايضا استهداف همم باقي
همم يعني المناطق التي يتم منها اذا تم
طبعا استهداف شبه جزيره القرم ايضا كانت
هناك تصريحات حاده على لسان المتحدث باسم
الكرمليند ميتر بيسكوف الذي وصف الحديث عن
امكانيه ارسال الدبابات المانيه الى همم
اوكرانيا بانه امكانيه نقل الصراع الى
مستواه جديد وحذر ايضا من ذلك بعد ذلك همم
كانت هناك ايضا تصريحات لنائب رئيس مجلس
الامن القومي الروسي بميترميديف الذي وجه
رسائل مباشره الى الدول المشاركه غدا في
اجتماعات همم قاعده رانشتاين قال بان على
اولئك الذين سيحدرون هذا الاجتماع همم
ادراك والعلم بان روسيا لا يمكنها كقوه
نوويه خساره حرب تقليديه والا فان ذلك
يعني همم اندلاع حرب نوويه بحسب بحسب
بتعبيره وشدد كغيره من المسؤولين من الروس
على ان روسيا ماضيه االاحين تحقيق اهداف
تطلق عليه بالعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
ياتي ذلك بالتزامن طبعا مع زياره اجرها
وزير الخارجيه سيرغي لافروف الى بلاروسيا
حين حين التقى الرئيس البيلاروسيا
اليكساندر لوكاشيكو وايضا وزير الخارجيه
البيلاروسين من خلال هذا الاجتماع كانت
هناك رسائل ايضا واضحه من قبل لا ظروف الى
جيران اوكرانيا بين قوسين او جيران
بيلاروسيا الغربيين قال بان هناك مخاوف من
تمدد النيته هو بان روسيا وبيلا روسيا في
الوقت المناسب تواصلتا الى اتفاقيات مهمه
في ما يخص الدفاع المشترك ونستمع الى ما
قاله ظروف في هذا الشهر
ناقشنا
نهج غير البناء للولايات المتحده واتباعها
من خلال توزيع الناتو واقتراب بنيته
العسكريه الى حدودنا وكذلك
ان تصعيد الاوضاع العسكريه لا يمكن ان
يبقى دون اهتمام كبير من قبل دولتين
فالغرب
العسكريه على دول الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
من الخطوره ان تهزم دوله نوويه في حرب
تقليديه هذا هو الموقف الروسي يتحول الى
عيسى في المانيا
وامكانيه قراءه هذه الهزيمه يعني اشكال
مختلفه وقراءتها مختلفه لانه روسيا خرجت
من الاتحاد السوفيتي خرج من افغانستان وهو
قوه نوويه وامريكا خرجت من فيتنام وهي قوه
نووي لكن اجتماع وزير الدفاع على الماني
والامريكي بحث سبل دعم اوكرانيا هل هل هذه
التصريحات الروسيه الى اي مدى لها وزن في
صناعه القرارات في مثل هذا الاجتماعات
اليوم مثلا تحدث ايضا تحدثت الحكومه
الالمانيه وتحدث باسمها السيد فولفو ايضا
بان المانيا لن تسمح بهزيمه بسقوط
اوكرانيا قالت بانها ستفعل ما في وسعها
لفوز اوكراني بهذه الحرب
بوليس بيستريوس وهو اول وزير دفاع ياتي في
هذه المرحله وهو برجل وليس بامراه قال في
المؤتمر الصحفي مع نظيره الامريكي بان
معركه اوكرانيا الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا
هي فرصه للحلفنيته لاظهار قوته ولاعاده
البعث انبعاثه القديم باعتبار احد اهم
القوى وباعتبارها ايضا مركز القوه الكبرى
في العالم الان هذا الخطاب الذي ياتي به
همم بوليس وزير الدفاع الالماني الجديد
لقى صدى ايضا عند نظيره الامريكيه الذي
اعتبر بان المانيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مهمين في في معركه او في الدعم
اوكراني في هذه
السؤال الاخر الذي اتجه اليه المؤتمر
الصحفي بين الوزيرين هو مدى دعم اوكرانيا
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يتجاوز تلك الخطوط
الحمر التي وضعها المستشاره الالمانيه
سابقا وهي الماء وهي وهي الدعم اوكرانيا
بالسلاح النوعي ما ما يلاحظ اليوم تحدثت
عنه الكثير من الاصوات الالمانيه خصوصا ما
تحدث عنه رئيس تحري صحيفه فيلد عندما قال
بان الغربه كان كانت المانيا كان الغرب
ينظر الى المانيا بانها متردده ولكن الغرب
الان
يترقبوا ما ستقدم عليها المانيا اعلنت
المانيا اليوم في مصدر حكوميه الرسمي
لوكاله رويترز بانها المانيا لم ترسل
الدبابات اثنين الى اوكرانيا الا اذا
ارسلت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الدبابه
الثقيله القتاليه الامريكيه لاوكرانيا هذا
الامر وهذا التصريح اليوم قد نرى انعكاسته
غدا في الاجتماع في راميشتاين لان
المحددات يبدو بان التوافق برلين حصرت
شروطها لتمديد لمده اوكرانيا بالدبابه
الثقيله القتاليه الى مو الى الى شراكه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى ان تقدم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالامر نفسه
لذلك هناك اراء تتحدث اليوم بان المانيا
قد توافق غدا في اجتماع رمشتاين بارسال
هذه الدبابات خصوصا ان الوزير الجديد في
المانيا وزير الدفاع الجديد يختلف عن
الوزير السابقه لانه رجل امني له خبره وله
علاقه جيده مع القوات المسلحه الالمانيه
كما تحدث عنها لنستمع الان ما قاله وزير
الدفاع الامريكي في هذه النقطه
لقد كان وقتا مطربا للامن الاوروبي
والعالمي ولكن على الرغم من الازمات التي
سببها الغزو الروسي غير المبرر لاوكرانيا
بقيت المانيا صديقا حقيقيا للولايات
المتحده ومدافعا قوي عن حلفائنا وقيامنا
سنستمر في دعم الشعب الاوكراني وهو يقاوم
العدوان الروسي ويدافع عن سياده ارضه اشكر
الحكومه الالمانيه على كل ما فعلته من اجل
ان تعزز اوكرانيا عمليه الدفاع عن اراضيها
ومن اجل المساهمتها التي لا تقدر بثمن في
تدريب المدافعين عن اوكرانيا